hello
hey Hey sir how much you had to drink
tonight uh nothing sir nothing at
all I'm sorry I'm was little my inro you
almost ran me over it was me that you
almost ran over when you were driving
right by me okay at when there's police
lights liting lighting up the the road
over there I'm so sorry it's just been
up that night where was on our way home
and we were leaving you want steping out
for me
yeah nice truck expensive truck sorry so
where are you coming from tonight coming
over here leav the beach home leaving
the beach heading home I know nothing to
drink tonight no
sir so it's just you said they
passengers yeah just
passengers but I can smell on your
breath okay I'm I'm sorry it's it's Dam
I was just kissing I
girl apologize that's that's what you're
going to say that you're kissing your
girlfriend so that's why you have
alcohol coming off your breath I'm sorry
sorry yeah that was that's what
I okay well would you mind if I check
your eyes and make sure you're safe to
be driving sir yes sir
okay it's hard going to kill your
[Music]
lights why don't you just put your feet
together for me he touching like my
hands at your sides you wear glasses of
contact sir no sir okay perfect have you
hit your head really really hard in the
last 24 hours to where you caus you the
bomet or something
um about in the last 24 hours okay so
you see that red light on my pen yes sir
I want you just follow with your eyes
your eyes only don't move your head I
want you to keep your chin level for me
though don't move your head just your
eyes
just your
you're moving your head okay I need you
to keep your head still put your nose
faceing me and just move your eyes okay
sure
one
you I got neck problems here I'm
sorry I can't turn my head that far keep
your your chin level for me you're
looking up keep your chin
level problem I was just trying to I
can't like yeah I don't want you to move
your head you keep moving your head I
understand that but I can't I if I if I
look too far that way I have for my head
my back is a little just your eyes you
don't need to move your head that's fine
okay keep your turn level for me though
okay no problem there we go we're going
to just pass
again I can't only look so far then
without without my neck turning I can't
only look so far I need you to follow my
instructions okay keep your chin level
for me your chin is still on that level
there we go okay well you're holding it
above my head I'm sorry I'm not holding
above your head okay okay keep your feet
together for me heels and Toes
touching here we
go
nice and
slow now what do body cams like this
show you that it's an unpredictable
world right and sometimes s in that
world you're going to need a lawyer but
finding the right legal help is so
important and let me take a minute then
to thank attorney Tom and Associates for
sponsoring this body cam you see whether
you were injured in a car wreck or
Refinery explosion or the victim of
securi fraud or received a notification
that your information was included in a
data breach developed an illness as a
result of a bad drug or toxic exposure
and there are so many other situations
attorney Tom can help you see what Tom
and his team do so well is they not only
have the legal knowledge of course but
they have genuine empathy for their
clients and having someone you can trust
is invaluable and by the way every call
is free it's private you'll be speaking
with a member of his team straight away
you won't pay a dime until you win which
just shows their commitment to your
success and they have an impressive
track record in tough tough cases and
look if your case is not the best fit
for attorney Tom and his team don't
worry because they still may be able to
recommend you a lawyer because they have
a national network of attorneys they can
refer you to with attorney Tom and his
team you're not just hiring a lawyer
you're getting powerful allies who are
committed to Justice and your well-being
so if you've suffered an injury and you
need legal support click the
attorney.com bodycam link pinned in the
comments for a free consultation or dial
855t
Wiz
do you want to take out of the car for a
second I don't want you out of the car
okay sorry we going to go up two times
just
tries
last I'm going do I'm going to move
around your face like this in a circle I
want you to follow with your eyes going
to bring it towards the bridge of your
nose I'm not going to make contact with
you it's going to feel like your eyes
want to cross okay just go ahead let
them do what they do naturally all right
here we
go you want them to follow the follow
the L yep follow the
light one more
time
last thing I want you to do is look up
in the sky for me close your eyes I
promise not a trick okay look turn the
right so your feet are together for me
heels and Toes touching heels and Toes
touching there you go tost your head
back look in the sky and close your
eyes try to
relax can you me please all right you
can relax all right sir here's where I'm
at I am seeing some signs of impair I'm
going to ask are you willing to further
participate and some f some body
exercises yeah yeah okay I want you to
come over here just hang
tight the driver
the actually we're going to we're going
to do it right over here
okay
that line looks a little bit better now
that one it's it's cuz it's wet so my
tape's not going to stick here so I'm
going to make sure that
uh I think this one's
no probably these ones we're going to go
over
here all right just stand right here at
the top of the line for me start just by
asking you a few personal questions can
you state your full name for me
Nicholas okay what race do you identify
with loaded question question yeah I
have I have to ask okay I mean that's
that's a you know okay white want your
data breath sir July 27th 1990 okay um
do you any physical
defects aside from injuries um no okay
are you sick or injured right
now uh other than
what do you do for work I'm sorry what
do you do for work I am a music producer
music producer okay all right um are you
diabetic no
sir
BL sugar but not diabetic yeah you take
insulin no sir okay you take any
medications prescribed to
you
um I asked you already do you wear
glasses or contacts you said no um
what's your house of Education uh GD GED
okay have you have you consumed any
alcoholic beverages in the past 24 hours
uh no sir have you used any illegal
drugs and narcotics to include marijuana
in the past 24 hours no sir Okay this
may sound like a silly question do you
know you're left from your right yes sir
okay I have to ask some people don't
know which one's your left which one
your right you got it okay so this first
exercise is called the walk and turn
what I'm going do is put you on a
starting position and once I put you in
that starting position I don't want you
to move from the starting position okay
so starting position you don't want to
move from the starting position yep once
I put you in it okay but I'm going to
show you everything I'm going to
demonstrate it for you I'm going to give
you the instructions ask you if you have
any questions and then we'll address
those questions okay you see this line
that's painted down in front of you yes
sir you see anything that may prevent
you from walking in out line any
potholes rocks or sticks in the way uh
obstructing it not no no okay you feel
there's any reason why you can't walk
down that line uh aside from the rain no
sir I don't think it's raining that hard
no it's not raining
anymore okay all right so the starting
position is going to be like this okay
once you go and place your left foot on
the
line yep take your right foot place it
directly in front of your left foot with
the heel of your right foot touching the
toes of your left hands at your side I
need you to remain remain in that
position TR I finish the instructions
okay when I tell you to begin you're
going to take nine Heel To Toe steps on
this line touching Heel To Toe on each
step with no space in between is this
step one or do we your step's going to
be their back foot I'm going to explain
it to you okay and I'm going to demon
yes sir at the end of your ninth step
you're going to make a turn in which I'm
going to show you and you're going to
take nine more hle toe steps back down
the line while you do this you're going
to keep your hands down at your sides
look down at your feet at all times and
count each step out loud so that I can
hear you okay count
29 it's going to look like this I'm
going to demonstrate it I'm going to
demonstrate it for you okay watch me
okay 1 2 3 and so on until you get to
nine on your ninth step leave your front
foot planted on the line take your back
foot off make a STS of small steps just
like this to turn yourself around while
PIV on that front foot and once you
completed the turn I want you to return
back down the line with nine more heel
to steps the back foot's going to be
your first step I'm going to show you
again one 2 3 4 and so on until you get
to nine okay now I want during exercise
I want you keep your hands at your sides
okay look down at your feet at all the
times kind out out loud I stop so I can
show you the turn I don't want you to
stop okay once you start the exercise
don't stop walking don't stop walking
until you've completed it you understand
the exercise yes sir you all the
instructions yes sir okay do you have
any questions I mean it's a lot but yeah
sure I can do it one 139 here and turn
around back 139 just I explain yes sir
all right do you have any more questions
that that'll be it all right so when
you're ready you can
[Applause]
begin
5 7 8 9
turn here just I
explain all right you can relax sir you
want to face me yes all right so we'll
step over here for a minute this next
exercise is called the oneel leg stand
okay what I'm going to do is have you
stand with your feet together for me
heels and Toes touch like mine heels and
Toes touching sorry hands at your
sides got some heels and Toes touching
yeah all right hands at your sides yeah
got some knee injuries here so it
depends which leg we're working with
okay I'm going to give you the option to
go with either leg both are a little
messed up so we'll see okay are you able
to do this exercise I hope so I mean I
used to ride dirt bikes so my knees are
a little not happy but all right let me
go through the instructions okay and you
can tell me if you can do it or not all
right so this is hands at your side this
is the starting position I need you to
remain in that position until I finish
the instructions you understand sir yes
sir okay so when I tell you to begin
you're going to raise a leg of your
choice probibly 6 in off the
ground I'm sorry my feet were rubbing
guess I just give myself like a half an
inch of space I'm they're together I
just okay I can't press them like that
but you're going to you're going to
raise it up Pro 6 in off the ground
which about the high of sod can just
like this okay point that raised foot
forward so the foot is parallel with the
ground which foot okay the raised foot
all right while keeping both of your leg
listen while keeping both of your leg
straight and look down at your ra foot
and count out loud 1,001 100002 1003 and
so on until I tell you to stop counting
during exercise I want you to keep your
hands at your sides don't use them for
balance I want you to sway I want you to
hop and I don't want you to put your
foot down if you do happen to put your
foot down pick it back up continue
counting where you left off don't start
over so for example if you drop your
foot on 1005 once you regain your
balance pick it back up 1,6
1708 and so on and T how you to stop
counting okay do you understand the
instructions uh I think so any
questions no which say will you be using
to raise up um I I'd prefer to balance
on my they're both messed up so will
just go with my right one your right leg
okay I want to stand on my right leg
okay whichever one you once you raise
the leg up though I don't want you to
switch legs okay okay all right I'm hold
on give me a second hold on can I just
run I don't need you practicing any
there's no practices okay but okay I
don't run my KN they're both a little
messed up which one would you want to
raise up I just want to feel which one
hurts worse that's that's all I'm trying
to say cuz I I mess up above my knees
okay
cool uh I'll lift up the right one your
right leg okay I will start my time when
you pick up your leg and begin counting
okay whenever you're ready in my knee or
straight remember leg straight right
okay both our legs are going to be
straight when you do this
okay whenever you're
ready one two three 4 5 6 1 6
1009 100 hands at your
sides1
20134 remember hands at your sides
2019 you can
stop can I here NOP you can stop all
right next exercise called the finger to
nose all right what I'm going do is have
you stand with your feet together for me
heels and Toes touching bring your hands
up like this and close them extend your
pointer fingers bring them down and turn
your palms forward this is the starting
position I want you to remain in this
position until I give you the further
instructions okay you understand all
right so I'm going to tell you too
you're going to tot your head back
you're going to close your eyes okay
you're going to hear me say left or
right okay when you hear me say left
you're going to bring your left hand up
and touch the tip of that finger to the
tip of your nose and immediately put it
back down to your side in one foot
motion when you you hear me say right
you're going to do the same exact thing
you're bring your right hand up and
touch the tip of your finger to the tip
of your nose and immedately put it back
down to your side and one fluid motion
now for the purpose of this exercise
these are the tips of your fingers okay
these are the pads of your fingers and
these are the sides all right so I'm
going to show you again if this was an
example of your nose tip of the finger
tip of the nose not the pad not the
sides the tip of your finger okay I want
you to touch the very tip of your nose
not the top bottom or the sides of your
nose but the very tip of your nose just
the one me stand like this yep you're
going to stand just like that but I'm
going to tell you remember if I say left
boom if I say right boom and right back
down okay tip of the finger to the tip
tip of the finger to the tip of your
nose Okay do you understand my
instructions yes sir do you have any
more question do you have any questions
no sir all right sir so your hands are
here feet are together tilt your head
back look in the sky close those eyes
for me keep those eyes
closed
left right
left right his eyes closed eyes are
closed are you squinting
closed
left all right you can relax I have one
last exercise for you you can relax for
a minute all right this one's called
modified Romberg balance sounds a lot
harder than it is okay all right so I
want your feet together for me heels and
Toes touch like Min hands at your sides
and as you remain that position try give
you the instructions you understand sir
yes sir all right so when I tell you to
you're going to tilt your head back
you're going to close your eyes you're
going to hear me say
begin when you hear me say begin I want
you to remain in that position until you
feel that 30 seconds has passed in your
head not out loud
I'm going to go through the instructions
again okay yes sir
so when I say begin you're going to til
your head back okay you're going to
close your eyes you're going to hear me
say begin and when you hear me say begin
I want you to remain in that position
until you feel that 30 seconds has
passed in your head not out loud so til
my head back closed why is it count to
30 however you like to do that you're
going to estimate 30 seconds in your
head not out loud okay once you feel you
reached 30 seconds in your head you're
going to bring your head fold over open
your eyes and say stop that's it you
understand the instructions you have any
questions no sir all right remember
don't start your estimation until you
hear me say begin okay okay all right
tilch your head back close those
eyes
[Applause]
begin
like
TDCJ TDCJ Texas Department of Criminal
Justice I am a prison
worker no I am helping I would never
even you remember my instructions say
stop oh stop all right sorry all right
good together like no good we're going
to come over
here FR of the vehicle here back relax
all right explain everything to
you what I'm going to do is I put you in
two handcuffs cuz you're kind of a got
some big shoulders there
okay relax I'll explain everything to
you one step at a time all right
11 they're not too tight are they no so
okay I'm going to lock them so they
don't move on
you all right so going to place you
under arrest for DUI next part of my
investigation is a breath tests to
determin alcohol content are you willing
to provide me a sample of your
breath um sure sure um what's if if I if
I don't what what's let explain it to
you outcome if I don't let me explain it
to
you now requesting that you submit to
lawful test of your breath for the
purpose of determining alcohol content
will you take the test would you say yes
now you're asking what happens if you
don't um if you refuse to take the test
of request of you your driving PR will
be suspended for a period of one year
for the first refusal or 18 months if
driving has been previously suspended or
if from previously find under State
Statute 32735 215 which is the Bo Bui
voting statute for refusing to submit to
a lawful test of your breath R the blood
additionally if you refuse to take the
test I requested of you and if your drug
and privilege has been previously
suspended or from previously find under
State Statute
32735 215 for refusal to submit to a
lawful test of your
bre you will be committing and
misdemeanor in addition to any other
penalties which can be imposed by
refusal to submit to the test I request
is admissible to evidence any criminal
proceeding yeah you can go ahead and
take a look at it now I can't hold it
I'm sorry I got
you are you a CDL holder no sir huh no
sir
you understand that sir good
slow still reading boss
man all right well listen I read it to
you okay I'm still reading man I'm sorry
I'm I'm still reading I've read it to
you what it basically says is that if
it's the first time you refuse you lose
your license for a year if it's a second
or subsequent refusal so if you're
refusing to pass it's going to be an
18mth suspension on your license and
it's an additional charge for for it
okay for for refusing so with that said
I'm going to ask a final time if you're
willing to give me a sample your breath
I speak to my legal counsel now when it
comes to impi consent no you don't get a
legal counsel okay there's no legal
no not when it comes to imply consent no
sir
okay breathalizer
um
okay you understand what I'm saying to
you yes sir it's up to you uh I can't
make a
decision you can't make a decision no
sir I can't make a decision okay so this
is what I'm going to do I'm going to
take you down to the instrument I'm
going give you the opportunity down
there to provide simp since you're
indecisive I just I'm indecisive I'm
sorry okay that's fine spread your
stance for
me ni and wide and
wide hold on hold on
earplugs ear plugs
plugs
I know it's proced right we're going to
walk over here to my side
[Music]
okay got up a
little
[Music]
all right so I just have a seat inside
here for me watch your head as you step
in okay
sir he's impaired driving it's impaired
mhm he's currently in custody for DUI
DUI did he did he
blow okay we're at that point right now
he's asking if he's willing to blow
up cool let me find my real quick see
what this is crazy sorry about this it's
all
right basically the if he refuses he's
just going he's going to lose his
license I think he has refused I think
that's that's where we are with it a
second so if he f is he's going to have
the opportunity to go to a driver's
license hearing where he can get a
hardship driver's
license um if this is his first DUI then
there's methods they can use to um
reduce the the charges I me there's
different things they can do with your
attorney you should be able to figure
all that out yeah he say this his first
de R he should
be what was he doing was he speeding or
what was his deal move over excuse me
move over what does move over mean
officers are work on the side of the
road you change lanes he went by us at
boy so they take anywh to 49th Street
we're going to take him to the main
station we're going to give him the
opportunity to I think he's refused so
we're going to give him the opportunity
to still provide a breath sample
regardless and then um if it still if it
if if he still
refuses then um he'll just get a DUI
citation one is going after
he's got to spend 8 hours from the time
of the arrest where's the main station
6:45 Pier Street is that downtown yes
sir is that across from the empty park
over there yes sir
yeah what's going on those two they're
just yelling and screaming she's very
upset what's what's uh
just he says he can make up his
mind to instent and
[Music]
uh yeah you're going to have to do that
regardless killing people on the road
and instead of chasing people killing
people we're sitting here being a fad
piece
of no I will pass all the soety test
give need soety test
that's
his that back was trying to down is not
working no yeah it's just standard
procedure here for me it's always some
some type of BS drama let's see what he
wants to do okay
well you the officer said he's down at
the downtown station across that Park
where we were we were going down and
feeding all the homeless people down
there I think that's the one right down
there
all right
so well there's no reason for you to
stay up there both of and not going bail
him out that should be it he's going to
spend 8 hours hold on second I'm sorry
was that b he's going to spend 8 hours
in custody he's going to be the 8 hours
he's got to spend 8 hours by state law
he's got to spend 8 hours in custody
okay well he's going to spend 8 hours in
custody and uh then I'll get him out to
I talk to
him uh
good can you come back here Qui I can
take her and the car of the house want
to I'll run about if you trust me just
one second I'm asking
585 can he talk to him real
quick okay can you back up so we can
talk to him real quick I was going to
yeah I can do that I was just going to
get your phone number real quick for
him and that was so I can get us
property um so he'll be able to call you
once everything once he gets down the
county M he be to call you from there U
usually they have a cell phone but he
wanted me to get number for I'm going
put it with this property okay um also
the officer said it' be 8 hours before
he could get so there's no reason for me
to go down there and hang around on that
sir like for a call make sure that's on
high ring so you don't miss it yeah so
minus about to see he he'll get out
10:00 10 yeah as long as he blows under
an 05 he'll get out at 10:00 all right
cool yeah I'd love
to open the door open the
door you good bubba yeah all right
cooling
my whatever I you I'm sorry I'm
emotional yeah I worked at Mid pres I
think you guys and I can't blow that
long got to blow
harder I'm my exploring start that's as
hard as I can blow sorry Google
[Music]
me I'm sorry I'm sad like I was a
commissary manager and I I sat with
people who did BWI the boting while and
T and I was like I didn't know that was
possible
no she didn't blow hard enough I can
blow harder I I don't have a lot of lung
capacity I know how to do this I'm not
dumb consistent I'm trying I have a
little
lungs me it's funny I know it I'm
telling you like you guys are being
so to work in a prison I hat
everyone good I'm not doing anything
wrong big deep breath and
blow you got to blow harder and
consistent consistent keep going keep
keep going keep going keep going keep
going like my lungs are this
wide I don't need that what am I do with
that sell it on my only F like
thanks I'm not drunk I'm emotional I'm
sad yeah why AR we getting them racing
among bowling Booth racing all
day I'll do another one I'm not drunk
I'm sad I used to work at a prison I was
com talk for 2 seconds so you can get
your breath because you're not given a
complete sample cuz it's under the limit
and you don't believe me yes that's not
why if it was under the limit it would
say it was under the limit it's just
saying she's talking too much all right
big deep breath saying I can't breathe
that deep all
right I'm going to like pass if I go to
the hospital you going to pay for me to
the hospital
no
no check I
can
125125 I don't know double and half
over he was sitting the car I couldn't I
couldn't tell but if he was standing in
front of me I could tell if he was drunk
I just looking at he look like he was
dring
sign yeah he I mean he didn't
[Music]
do oh
okay he didn't do well in the F
[Music]
FR and honestly I don't know what the
other officer
saw I could come on I saw he didn't do
that W oh
well if it's his first DUI he should be
okay yeah it
is he's just going to have to go through
a bunch of different steps and your
attorney should be able to take him
through those different steps yeah he
had already he had already started
telling me what you had just told me
about the hardship license and yes the
DUI school and the whole thing all right
he's going to have to jump through a
bunch of
Hoops and hopefully uh maybe attorney
will be able to work through it with you
best how strip drinking every every
problem I've ever had in my life
revolves around somebody drinking
alcohol mhm you know
[Music]
100% fortunately this is all we do all
night long is take I don't know how you
do junks off the road I don't know how
you do up especially people keep running
their Mouse man just I I walk them all
up
got to have patience of a saint I guess
I guess so I don't know how you do
it they push your button
sometimes just kind of how far you can
get away with it that's
all well that are that was are more than
flexible I know a lot of people that
wouldn't C any that car
this day and age we have no
choice try we have to remain as
professional as possible and in doing so
you have
to be
flexible
[Music]
how long has he been
married oh my gosh couple
years couple
years I'm I'm really surprised he was
drinking because I was living at 9:00
and I he was at my house and he just
finished working out you know get done
training arms and then he was going to
go pick her up because he had to be
there 10 and so as we were working I
just feel really good I'm not not going
to drink anything tonight that's why I
was surprised all of a sudden I get this
call that he's getting pulled over from
DUI and knucklehead screamed to me on
the phone soon as I heard that I knew
there was a problem and I heard her
attitude you know I didn't know if she'd
got him in trouble or if he'd been
drinking but I was really surprised
when you guys said he was
Dr
that's the other officer said again he's
got alcoh his
[Music]
breath I went by there
10 cuz I had uh a couple of my friends
coming Town Jason alen's DJ was there
and so I went by a 10 I stayed till 4 11
and when I was there he didn't drink
anything in front of me CU he was right
there there DJ and I was sitting this
close next to him and he so he must have
started drunking after I
left you one he must drun like Sal or or
something something changed I mean I
smelled it when I came up on it but I
didn't you know
I he ducked his head away from me so I
couldn't look in his eyes yeah eyes are
usually the window to the world so yeah
couldn't figure out
yeah how are you can we help you uh yeah
I came here for to help Drive Tana or
the other person at home oh they're
already gone oh they're already left
yeah yeah okay all right thank you yeah
I thought she didn't that there last you
guys have a good night yeah you
too
okay
I wonder who they were pull in over
there don't think I either one of those
people dve my son's truck
on